after the 2016 elections some school
choice advocates hope for a huge federal
choice initiative but the last two
decades of federal k-12 policy
demonstrates why that might not be so
wise big bold Washington reforms can
misunderstand the important differences
between communities generated bulky
clumsy programs and as a result engender
resentment among local stakeholders so
choice advocates might thank Uncle Sam
for his interest but ask him to step
back for 25 years states and locals have
led on school choice and a great effect
today three million children attend
charters another half million are using
the various private school choice
programs this has been built on a
humbler approach to policy making then
swift certain DC initiatives it elevates
parents local nonprofits and state
leaders those who know their communities
inside now and who will have to live
with the consequences of their decisions
yes they might move more slowly at first
and make course corrections along the
way but the result can be smart tailored
programs that have deep local support we
should continue to trust federalism and
localism when it comes to school choice
what do you think about Uncle Sam's role
in school choice let us know in your
comments and to learn more read my
article in the AEI publication this way
up also let us know what other topics
you'd like our scholars to cover in 60
seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI